do you have a lighter shirt because this
is I look like angelically bright right
now you look great okay
you look great it symbolizes you well
hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jesus
apparently Jesus is my brother and my
Lord and Savior I'm Anthony Alba well
today my brother and I we're gonna watch
the trailer the new comic-con trailer
that released that whatever I'm saying
this all wrong the third trailer for
interstellar yeah um seeing the trailers
I saw the trailer the first teaser
trailer where that country dude talking
a lot and the trailer Mario conahey yeah
yeah I liked the second trailer - I
still don't know what this movies about
I think it's about going into space
that's all you know well I think it's
about entering a black hole I'm sorry
I'm spacing it's I think they're
entering a black hole because that's
like this spherical weird-looking thing
and the spaceships crossing the
threshold
can we just time travel to a part where
I could have had a really good joke you
said your spacing I'm spacing out yes
I'm spacing a no pun intended
good old daddy taught us jokes like that
all right you just had it open I know
there we go
you weird habits I do why would you
close it mainly consist of a lot of
different drugs drugs really the wolf of
Wall Street probably defines my life the
mergers really yeah we got away for this
s this how rod is you don't download
trailers you watch it straight from the
internet unfortunately we can't skip the
ad it's good ad there's black people in
it
really showing that versity in our
country right now frozen defines my life
yeah say wolf of Wall Street and the
Passion of the Christ
[Music]
we used to look up in the sky and wonder
that our place in the stars they just
look down and worry about our place and
then dirt
[Music]
go for main engine start t-minus 10 we
must confront the reality that nothing
in our solar system can help us 9 I've
got kids professor how long would I be
gone
hey I'm asking you to trust me
7 you have to talk to me Amerika 6 need
to fix this before I go 5 main engines
start
could you told her you're going to save
the world No
and become a period three the thing
becomes really clear too
now's the time make sure your children
feel safe
[Music]
and back
[Music]
I love you forever potentially habitable
worlds right within our reach and save
us from extinction
here we go
you just think about your family that
you have to think bigger than that I'm
thinking about my family and millions of
other families
it's the one thing that princess
diamonds
do not go gentle into that good night
old age should burn and rave at close of
day
rage rage
against the diner
if you are
[Music]
we'll find a way we always have
[Music]
I got goose bumps that's a new style for
trailers have the main character cry
through a good third no I mean the audio
just cutting out like that I haven't
seen that before
like Michael Bay's started the whole
thing with Texas Chainsaw Massacre with
blinking behind the screen and then that
became which you saw in every single
trailer I'm sure we're gonna see a lot
of that do you know how much research he
did for that movie I don't know anything
about olan you know I already did a ton
of research I can't give you an exact
estimate but I know for a space travel
yeah because I'm trying I was looking
and looking at it I was trying to figure
out what kind of space trouble he was
doing because there's different kinds if
you're to be realistic about it are you
interested in this stuff I am now okay
well there's something called the
al-kabir drive a Mexican scientist back
in 94 proposed this theory of a thing
that instead of you because you can't go
faster than the speed of light so but
what you can do in theory is bend space
and time around you so that it's like
you fold space and time and you move
forward quicker that way so you're not
actually traveling forward you're
bending the space around you to move
forward so you'll cross the universe in
an instant bending space and time around
that's the Alcubierre drive the other
one is using wormholes
that's probably what that is as
wormholes is if you can stabilize a
wormhole you could jump to other parts
of the universe but in science we
haven't figured out a way how we would
kit back or where we would end up if
there would be ways to sustain life on
the other side of that wormhole and the
other way is to just nuts well those are
the two ways that I can think of the
otherwise would you would be you would
actually need to repopulate within the
spaceship as if you're got a little mini
earth traveling through space it nuts
that's not what that movie is doing this
family knows a lot about that stuff and
like him and I just really studied space
it looks pretty yeah and now it does
look pretty well I like about the
trailers that it seems like there's this
really grand scope of a bunch of crap
happening but they have they're mainly
putting a lot of focus on Matthew
McConaughey is just a character and I
don't really see that with a lot of
Nolan films really no I mean like the
character
like I remember Inception like yeah they
didn't want the same you know the the
the movie has good character but the
trailer doesn't really show you much of
that this one's really showing you like
no you're gonna go on this journey with
Matthew McConaughey and he cries a lot
he's a big crier
yeah I'm cried for like the beginning
looked like act one two and three he's
gonna cry biggest fan he's a good timing
though because he just did mud and he
did that we were yet AIDS Texas sold
party no Dallas but also yeah that one I
try being funny than I'm working okay I
missed it sorry yeah but having that
back-to-back and then this is a good
follow-up but in general he's not my
favorite actor Magic Mike which was good
to you and I can relate to that so we
have to do bread when we turned 18 it's
tough tough life you grew up on the
streets some male stripper no this movie
he does look like a good time idea I
mean they're not really showing you the
adventure so much I don't know if
there's gonna be a big adventure
it looks like my my impression from the
first trailer was that most of the movie
was just all the drama leading up to it
so this is gonna be like a build up
movie yeah I was told that a lot of it
is spent in space okay so I can't say by
who but I was told if you wake up dead
the next day alright guys well thanks
for recommending that trailer which was
a total [ __ ] to find by the way I don't
know why it was so it's a good idea to
yeah what the hell if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe right here and
Anthony has his own channel too where
they do reviews and their short films
he's a badass fighter you can subscribe
right here
I just remembered one other phone States
trouble good let's hear it okay so
there's these things called tachyons
it's a theoretical thing they're
theoretical particles no one's proven if
they exist or not
okay the idea behind them is they cannot
move slower than the speed of light they
have a range of speed but they cannot
move slower than the speed of light and
if you
were able to harness that and surround
your ship in it you could move faster
than the speed of light in theory using
tachyons Sphere saying you could like
LIGO but it's just that they're in I
think a lot of Sciences don't think
they're real but there are people
looking for them the cool thing about
them is that like Lightspeed can only
move at one speed the speed of light
there's no way to slow it down it just
goes at the speed that it goes whereas
tachyons have a dynamic range that they
can play with if they were real anyway I
don't think they're using tachyons I
don't think they're using the al-kabir
drive I think they're using a warp a
wormhole that's most likely that is
probably most likely that yeah that's
the closest thing work we've worked
that's the closest thing we are to
cracking moving faster than the speed of
light I think yeah if there's one thing
we're close to figuring out it's that
thing right there let's do some shout
out - you mean me Lord Auckland do a
shout out for me cuz it's almost my
birthday and I'm black Oh got another
black friend and I'm counting I got
three three black friends I'm working on
it you only have three I'm trying to get
more involved oh no I just made the
fourth one go to New Orleans seven
that's her name go to New Orleans go to
New Orleans yes black people you will
meet lots of nice black people there
they are awesome but they'll be same
like black people are awesome everywhere
no you can't take it back now it's not
like I can head it this okay
we're gonna keep it wrong all right but
yeah black people Rock man last thing I
saw of you guys was American Horror
Story season three what happened oh
nothing just some black goo do stuff and
got shot in New Orleans like they were
like pointing that out I was in New
Orleans last week and they were pointing
that out to us yeah I would love to
visit the set of all those terrifying
things that have I got photos for you
okay I think so okay me lord
is that a are you like African like
genuine African that's me no that's not
what I meant
I mean like are you from
Africa itself or you african-american
that's what I meant to say cuz me Lord
sounds like that doesn't sound like an
African name it could be an African it's
not me Lord I promise you you promise me
you know it's not an African name it
doesn't have a clique in it it's not an
African name doesn't have a quick name
like that
what okay that was racist that was very
recent so I'm telling you that's not
unlike a genuine African name that's
just a cool like YouTube name because
you know you're not authentic like
Denzel Washington
Andre Boyd didn't subscribe for weeks
now I feel like you get me Ryan I don't
know give me a shoutout
Veronica cracks me up by the way love
that chick man
keep it up I love Veronica - I love
Veronica - I would do things with her
let her know that comment on her channel
right now for me which one's Veronica
Veronica is the one from that 4/20 video
I just showed you if you don't use cute
you feel like you get me I feel like I
get you - you know what I mean like this
connection we have it's rare I feel like
we're two individuals that become whole
when we finally talk to each other you
know and you know I concur yeah I've
talked to my brother about you but I'm
literally frequently Andre he's probably
also black I will not make assumptions
this is a black theme today me Lord
if only was February I know I know
white History Month remember how great
white people are no entrance under
you're awesome you're awesome we like
you a lot thanks for subscribing and
comment or we'll talk cuz as we get each
other
Donald Hunter Veronica and Ryan should
be a couple it would be awesome and can
i have a shout out bro
it's not the trailer guy i'm the trailer
guy we gotta go a little bit more manly
okay that's gonna become Batman Veronica
and Ryan I'm going their business what
Veronica and Ryan should be a couple it
would be awesome and can I have uh
bro that's good good but a little bit
too Keanu Reeves that's what I like to
tell people no seriously black trailer
it's like no because because I need to
tell people I don't like to have a tan I
like to have the pale Keanu Reeves look
alright that's not relevant Donald you
are you have a nice name it reminds me
of a character I loved growing up Mickey
Mouse - I did there I threw you off no I
agree
oh no that makes sense I mean you just
hear Donald Donald Duck Oh Mickey Mouse
in the club yeah yes yeah it's all
relative I know it's awesome that you
get a Shadowhunter are you a real hunter
do you it's kind of funny that his
name's Donald hunter like a duck hunter
interesting like the video game exactly
maybe you're the inventor of the video
game I'm frustrating growing up being I
would have been really frustrating
especially if you're like a nerd like if
your name's jasmine and Aladdin just
came out and everyone's big in front of
you I can't imagine the amount of people
that called Donald hey Sutherland get
over here right right
well Donald Hunter Sutherland shout out
to you you stay classy San Diego know
better watch Mockingjay because you're
in it um you brought it back to call the
callback it's called a callback comedy
lesson number 14